dea
今から日本語な熱戦を行います
夏への手紙夏連日厳しい暑さが続いておりますがお前のせいだ
なぜお前のためにコピーをいくつか書いてみたとシャツが汗で背中に張り付く感覚好き
まつお久しぶりです
なんて本当は言いたくないんだけど首つり自殺をする理由が足りない
夏へ
家の中が家督期ぶりでいっぱいになったらと想像したことがある
夏へ日本には夏が好きだという不思議な奴がいる
彼らは爬虫類と呼ばれています末はビールザ
と言う奴がいるがこれは勘違いだ夏は蒸し暑くて嫌な季節
今の上段は日本語の方が面白い松江
日本では
あるの後でもなく梅雨の後に夏が来るなので暑さが少しずつではなく一気に激しくなる
のだ
そのため猛暑になれる暇がないいきなりプールの深い部分に織り込まれるというより神
様の存在を疑わせるような気分な蝉の声を聞くたびに
吐き気がする松江お前は暑すぎて人ゲーマー a 議員には汗をかく前は次て
ゲータレードを飲んでも喉が渇く
お前を暑すぎて頃の服を着てもダメージを受ける
夏へ cool-b ずなんて熱拷問の婉曲子だ
日本の夏僕が再生可能エネルギーをなるべく使おうとしている理由は
から茶道クジラが好きだからどんどんなくなっていく練ったよりのオランウータンが
かわいそうだから
いやそうじゃない僕ができるだけグリーンに息をとしているのは
前を経験しているからだ
これ以上熱くなると海面上所よりも僕自身が地球にとって危ない存在になるからだ
熱いて冷房をつければいいまあしたら風邪をひいてさらに熱が上がっちゃうけど夏
お前は暑すぎてウエブがみんな国に変えてしまう
うん
良いこともありなん
ni
て可能に帽子かぶってんだろうねええ